on
l'émission qui a eu que des femmes de
porter les femmes qui parlaient des
policiers c'est
ces revenus sauf que ce qui m'est arrivé
je te fasse tous les niveaux d'or et
cheveux d'un des diverses
on s'en prend aux personnes dont la
vulnérabilité est au plus haut niveau
c'est ça braille et ça n'a absolument
aucun sens c'est ce que tout le monde va
essayer de se protéger notre dame
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent que
nous sommes juste des alcools et que
nous sommes dit menteuse et tricheuse
des bonus même si pas les corps ou
quelle femme des valeurs principal
disque à reygades d'abou dhabi indigènes
où j'ai dû windisch lacie lance des
prises et l'hymne allemand
we want dance sûreté du québec police
officers who want to tell the stories à
zinder voice windows update val-d'or der
wiel de m6 décédée souffrait de
difficultés tout faire complet de sûreté
du québec houston et new world history
je suis sortie aux barres il ya une deux
agents qui m'ont arrêté ils disaient que
je te partout dans chemin dans la rue je
ne l'aimé pas tu vois même portiques et
christine what is she was val-d'or 110
km heure
évitez de d2 times annie ville de nema m
embarquer dans charge et lui demander si
je pouvais monter mes pantalons parce
que mes pantalons tombé s'est rendue à
milan fait que les images et moi je dois
le faire moi je dis non je porte une
touche puis si le cas précis mais il ya
l'entrée dans dans mon pantalon
il me dit que je peux te toucher comme
un jeu
christine bigaran chanter quoi ils
traitent tous fallait comme flint et
doivent ouvrir dans val d'or et le
modernisme à deux rondes de voir ni
ressource gabriel dumont débarquer une
chose roma battue moment donné des
coupes et dans do you un extincteur mais
faute j'avais des bleus avait des gars
tu sais que moi je me suis mis un joli
jeu via les gens que je vois me
souvenais de surface christine stand
night de police stationné mme kraft d'un
ex-marine surpris des deux dates
suivantes to fall comme plein d'audience
des assesseurs jeudi à lui que je
l'amenais un cours pilule magique
acquittent je pense qu'ils vont croire
la police ou et soule ont vérifié used
to take comme plein de police stationné
blake jean nohain vocale pour porter
plainte contre les policiers
surprising
j'étais en train de regarder la
télévision plus d'agents temps de soldes
les femmes qui parlaient des policiers
c'est survenu sur ce que ce qui m'est
arrivé je te l'allumé de la sauge une
chandelle bien j'ai pleuré j'ai vraiment
pleuré j'ai pleuré totally j'arrivais
pas arrêté de pleurer et de cordes de
gunino val-d'or tact l'isle-jourdain
tout acabit à bioule data longue
histoire de life in cherville toi je
travaillais dans le bas à chanter quand
j'avais fini mon chef joyeux toujours à
genre de police le petit est embarquée
du mandarin riposte à ces défis je pense
qu avait pas vraiment besoin de knight
rider sad to fuck them to protect
attestation
abandonner ma soeur et crier le disais
il ya une touche lui lol ils baissent et
pantalon ils disaient qu'est ce qui se
passait dans leur moi je crie après lui
je disais squat je te jure si tu touches
à ma soeur ne soint pour sortir de 10,6
vivante parce que je vois de dénoncer je
vais tout faire pour que tout le monde
le sache qu est ce que tu fais aux
familles
si ce n'importe quoi je criais je
voulais attirer son attention je voulais
je voulais qu il al haouz et la laisse
la laisse tranquille
et toi tu de police mène 30 ouvert si
vous en avez su résister et il est en
train de toucher pu tisser à l'autre
palissy et il vient voir ça c'est doux
comme la peau d'un bébé je l'entends
derrière j'ai entendu de la porte fermée
après
libre des policiers à chaque fois un
policier un policier mais j'utilise des
policiers parce qu'ils n'avaient
d'autres quittent elop qui était au
courant de ce qui se passait
deborah heinich kim chi minh à sept îles
chinoises détermine tout est à wall
street
un chauffeur ville j'ai hâte d'y être
notre s coiffure égard un touriste
creusot a choisi d'abord que je suis
venu comme un jeu débridé turgot rien du
tout madame bintou dembélé denis lauxire
au manège pédalos et d'arn inpi nous un
vernis marc daoud a et b à venir
et baignade aux jeux panarabes débat
mais je vous dois je m'allie nouveau
mardi
j'étais beau temps et pourquoi tu as
gardé le silence toutes ces années après
une de nous un ouvrage à qui j c'est à
dire au mois de mai nous dit médocs nina
simone de sentheim verbaux ménard
speaking à val d'or j'étais bouleversée
et ma première réaction ça a été ils
vont s'arranger tout le monde que la
fesse et au flanc
ça y est repos plus de gens au baume
sagouine
il faut qu'ils aillent vraiment une
enquête sérieuse de fêtes puis aller
chercher vérité savoir ce qui est arrivé
puis ceux qui ont protégé les autres
policiers doivent subir les conséquences
aussi marqué les accros bex nation
touriste accalmie dans l'histoire de val
d'or il faut se rappeler d'une chose
absolument incroyable c'est que à la
suite de la dénonciation médiatique de
ce qui s'était passé
jamais jamais on n'a vu le directeur
général de la sûreté du québec
monté au front et dire nous allons nous
attaquer au problème par une fois nous
positionnons policière de val d'or sont
professionnels ont la bonne information
c'est des policiers qui ont une bonne
réputation et du questionnement
mais de là à dire qu'on est en crise
donc je ne le pense pas on doit faire
quelque chose vous savez la loi sont des
indiens c'est la loi la plus raciste au
monde
isabelle parent en altitude à des
universités augmenteront votre
courtoisie au chef des ministres à
québec ce ministère public security
j'espère en déçoit sont encore plus à
risque
shittu decide to break dance y'avait pas
d'intérêt à tête il n'y avait pas
vraiment d'intérêt au revoir
la sécurité des autochtones des femmes
autochtones c'est ça qui me suis donc ce
que vous dites c'est que les femmes
autochtones
on les laisse tomber en partie oui
malheureusement quand que une enquête
criminelle là avec un autre corps de
police extérieur mais souvent mais il
n'y a pas d'accusation en bout de ligne
s'ouvre un bain ou au niveau des
procureurs et vont dire que y en avait
pas toute l'information pour aller plus
loin au niveau de la cour et c'est donc
finalement il ya plein d'étapes ou que
ça peut tomber qui y pose nécessairement
de suite et on devrait plus beaucoup de
technique pour justement que ça sorte
fait de façon publique oui les choses
qui peuvent déranger ou donner une
mauvaise image l'image l'image de sûreté
l'image des deux du gouvernement du
québec
c'est le grand québec et responsable la
sûreté du québec toujours le syndrome de
la pomme pourrie jusqu'à certains points
c'est le baril lui même qui pourrit les
pommes alors qu'est ce que le baril fait
pour empêcher que le phénomène se
déroule et c'est à la sûreté du québec
il faut poser la question et non pas
nécessairement policiers eux mêmes qui
sont pris dans la tourmente pour les
jours et gensana aubry sa façon
puisqu'en tant vos deux mains vestiges
kremlin cherche benq allemagne d'après
lui personne même pas de changer dès 2
heures du matin il m'a poussé je tombais
à tapis après un bar de mystery lâcheté
d'un banc de neige ce qui en fait il m'a
laissé leur dois partir ça nivelle
prescillia pas pâti à bangui pour 2012
au canada arc a consequence of practice
and i tried in saskatoon
at least puis un déjeuner semaine orford
dead frozen after having been à baden
outside of time between my dinh dinh thi
hanh toute la zone police officers who
comme vecteurs azote est positif
westwood
une québec 10 practice morceaux en zone
n en a plus que la cure géographique
tant mieux j'espère que c'est
nécessairement généralisée que tout le
monde
tous les policiers françois
régulièrement non mais que ça se fait ça
fait longtemps
we found the victims of 10 géographique
urgent cauberg we think this one hits à
moosch au maximum mireval d'or police
left right side of the website in and
for love tout à une forte ils étaient 2
avec moi j'étais parti moi j'ai servi
vers le chemin de capital fils à moussac
vraiment l'argent mais qu'elle est mort
ou s'il est amené les souliers de marche
à pied
par ce biais de sait combien de temps
ils se posent marché boisnard marie cuir
ce go in style & young woman à d'été
sauf desmet de sun yat sen no sleep
after having to much to drink et sécu
vraiment ainsi qu aux riches avaient
posé t ou villages et décider des
chambres de suivre la piste pilotage
bull très le joaillier aussi les
lumières que j'étais rendu à l'acte et
latady l'habitude outside sept îles
j'avais part j'avais froid puis j'avais
des petits souliers comme des petits
bottillons j'avais même posture que
j'avais pas de mitaines
il y avait une classe à schefferville
qu'on appelle tôt
il disait je n'ai pas dit s'ils allaient
débarquer d'abord puis redonné un pee
working and after la sûreté du québec
police officers from maniwaki
caroline arel de police des drogues
passe de cameron des drops des mof forme
tard le 10 heures tout dire
et tout et tout teenagers maisy odjick
jane alexander de kitigan zibi reserve
10 à maniwaki de news show sur l'icône
chili plainte de ford auteur distincts
m
despite la naissance de l énergie comme
pleine de rythme
oui surtout marqué l'un des stades et de
police alex norris se rendre compte par
exemple que les policiers plus jeunes
avaient des niveaux des tic
significativement moins élevé que leurs
collègues plus un jeu mais c'est plus
qu'on en voit dans les postes isolés de
la sorte et c'est clair c'est un c'est
un problème est de toute façon
pour ce qui est des jeunes policiers
qu'on en voit dans les communautés est
atteint il faut savoir que c'est pas des
postes qui sont privilégiés en général
par des policiers savent rien ils sont
déléguées il reste un jeune homme il ya
19 ans il ya vingt ans et dans la sûreté
du québec l'an général quand les gens
iront se poster y remettre sur un poste
très éloignées je t'en vas avec marie au
témiscamingue pilote tu travailles pas
tu as des indiens par tous et qui s'est
exilé ils sortent du cnt alors comment
ça se fait que c'est comme ça pourquoi
il ya des lois spéciales en général on
part de ces gens là vous écoutez
l'émission c'est fou l'ipo lobby comme
ignoble garrouste anthropologiste serge
bouchard kriss kross codec froid ni
favier
il ya deux first time in design noir
je faisais l'histoire complète de
christophe colomb jusqu'à la conversion
davy jones s'immobilisait des
patrouilles art et il était devant moi
puis je les avais pendant deux jours je
les fais de 1980 jusqu'à 86 87 yeux une
tomme des clipse 86 la crise donc et je
suis revenue en p4 de rouen
j'en ai fait et pour la grc est probable
la sûreté du québec jusqu'à temps qu'ils
couple et là tu tes couilles plus
d'argent pts c'est toujours ça
no one love ex police academy 2 1 ghz un
écran un déjeuner spip aux professeurs
jean boumsong wind of india company de
serge bouchard on nous attendait aussi
avec un groupe infernal dans beaucoup de
code le rôle de la formation était
d'essayer de leur montrer qu'ils avaient
autre chose dans la communauté dans une
communauté tu pouvais avoir peut-être 10
12 15 20 % de personnes qui étaient
alcooliques mais les 80% off dont les
voyez pas parce qu'ils se cachaient pas
que c'est ces gens lors qu'on voulait
faire découvrir aussi aux policiers
vendée posthume celle que d'autres ou
sentiers qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait pas
évident sept îles les plus de lui plus
qu'à les plus utilisés à cette série grc
et sur disque comme expliqué cécile a
toujours été un endroit très très sûr
moi j'étais une femme qui se bagarrent
aime beaucoup mais je défends des maps
multi assets y avait beaucoup de russes
jeannette pilot et non au today and
activists in style
j'ai failli te rennes et nice pour drive
si on saura ce défi côte est
c'est sûr que moi aussi je j'ai vécu
dans la drogue d'un boissons je suis ex
extérieur par un collègue
je ne suis a pris en main à 42 ans
cg 51 temps je vais bientôt cinq ans
thérapie de toute la consommation j'ai
vécu l'enfer comme d'autres femmes qui
en fait d'être présent j'en ai fait
aussi resteront en service a indiqué
gilles ouimet brisbane times particules
donc à jouer dans des petites c'est
d'eux que ceux des grains prisonniers
qui sont installés leur mais maintenant
ils ont des amis au complet dimanche des
partants tout nul qui mangent des
partants pin trop en arrière je pense
parce que je n'avais pas vu il y avait
plusieurs personnes se retourne en
arrière
oui je les attendais à rire
rayés l'audimat et son pied dans mon
double peine aux cantonales mais je
voyais rien je pouvais pas bouger
j'ai essayé de faire une poignée
d'endroits mon âme corps d'autres
ils m'ont dit qu'à avait pas de personne
pas tellement ce dessert contre zombies
via une sorte de zone d'impunité vous
êtes d'abord en région isolée
vous avez des postes qui sont pas
couverts par les médias qui sont pas
couverts par les journalistes une omerta
policière il ya une sorte de fatalité
finalement pour moyens c'est il n'a qu
il aime quand ce communiqué oxfam
il ya eu un racisme je dirais dures
violences physiques
ça nous rappelle le sud des états unis
exclusion des indiennes les hôtels les
indiens qui se font battre parce que il
parlera à cet abus des personnes abusées
femmes
on a les policiers qu'on aurait bien
avoir ils sont pas ils peuvent pas être
si différent de la population qui les
paient jusqu'à un certain point et dans
des contextes où les frictions les
tensions raciales sont souvent
extrêmement exacerbé comme c'est le cas
en abitibi dans beaucoup d'endroits mais
aussi sur la côte nord et ailleurs que
les policiers se retrouvent même pris un
peu dans le bain de vouloir jusqu'à un
certain point refléter ce que la
majorité blanche véhicule qu on image
c'est pratiquement normale de sem
attitude existe administrés public
security accordingly isabelle parent
works et je pense qu'on les perçoit un
peu comme dans la société générale
finalement avec beaucoup de réticence
certaine discrimination systémique de la
société à l'égard des autochtones et
encore plus à l'égard des femmes comme
une double discrimination
il faut que les femmes parlent les
enfants parlent et vite y aime pas puis
qu'ensuite la société disent ça suffit
on s'en occupe en priorité
de ministry of public sécurité dati
serait de sûreté du québec des notes
world one sera question email de
ministres clés
cinq ans vie donne
on a un droit de vivre en paix soit
valdes à lac simon
mais pour tous cas de la police des
descentes et protégés
emmanuel babeau montagnac canaan et le
manège et je fais à manger de points
j'aimerais rencontrer un jour de police
et j'aimerais tellement rencontrer plus
pouvoir le garder dans un phase pays
demander s'il ne reconnaît ci se
souvient de moi s'il sait que ça fait
plusieurs années que briser ma vie si je
sèche pas la seule
i